ah oui celle-là et bien vous êtes
géniaux les gars il fait c'est toujours
quelque chose dans ma famille ils ne
comprennent pas trop pourquoi je
n'arrive pas à avoir une relation de
plus de quelques mois tu devrais venir
chez mes parents avec moi vous dire a
conduit tomber amoureux toutes ces
années d'accord mais alors je t'adore
stater fera pas semblant d'être
ressemble à si t'as pas le choix
je peux voir leurs têtes quand on leur
dira et tu lui as dit quoi ta mère rien
du tout j'ai un cadeau de noël en avance
pour toi demain tu as un rendez vous
amoureux tu l'as trouvé sur danon c'est
un rendez vous arrangé j'ai zéro chance
pour que ça fonctionne
[Musique]
notre plan c'était de faire semblant
d'être tombés amoureux l'un de l'autre
c'est sympa de la part de ton ami
tu es le premier garçon que peter est
présenté à toute notre famille quand il
est avec toi il est l'heureux
[Musique]
les gays savent toujours faire un tas
truc tu vois et bizarrement ils ont tous
une obsession roman